okay we get it
the matrix digital program II
this is Neos dream about Trinity dying
and it's so detailed he dreams of the
guy clocking out at the end of his shift
was the motorcycle rigged with c4 or
something
ah full point zero zero one percent of
the bullets fired in the scene found
their target opening scene was just a
dream cliche also so much for that I'm
gonna show these people the world
without you mission that Neil promised
at the end of the first matrix I can't
say I fully understand your reasons for
volunteering well I can say it the guy
that played Tank got old diva and
demanded too much money
causing the screenwriters to invent both
link and his reason for joining the crew
why not Morpheus somehow heard this
conversation all the way back here movie
finds a clunky way to let us know what
now Oh bees name is we're gonna do what
commander Locke ordered us to do well
evacuate broadcast level return to Zion
so why the meeting why didn't everyone
head back to Zion after the order is it
so Morpheus could suggest one of the
ships stay behind this dude is somehow
unaware of neo supernatural powers also
showdown number one with Agent Smith
pushed to later in the film because I
guess Smith just wants to play games and
be coy but also probably the script look
I get it you're trying to show that neo
is so fucking awesome at fighting that
he's really only humoring these assholes
and even with upgrades they still can't
beat him the problem is that's fucking
boring and also I think the Wachowskis
are the only people on planet earth who
forgot neo could disintegrate agents by
jumping into them because he doesn't do
any of that in this entire movie also I
truly believe this movie suffers from
the same issue plaguing most Superman
movies the hero is too indestructible
for us to give a shit during the action
sequences alright now that I've killed
these agents time to fly out of here and
go to the oracles apartment all of a
sudden you should have seen it was
exactly like the first movie only way
more boring also it was Trinity who
asked the question but Morpheus is the
one with the phone so how did link hear
her and why did he specifically address
Morpheus with that answer he's doing
this Superman thing oh so he's breaking
someone's neck also DC Comics robber neo
number one if the Oracles true message
in the first movie was know thyself and
it was then why are neo and the others
completely powerless to do anything
without hearing from her again last time
they were positive they needed her
advice and she told me oh he wasn't the
one an outright lie
stalking these people are jacked into
some sort of flight control matrix down
in Zion why the four movie rips off the
robot mech suits from aliens also this
asshole quit doing his job before the
gate closed completely
slacker I want the ship ready to go as
soon as humanly possible I thought that
was the point of your ship coming back
anyway you needed to recharge you have
36 hours to go back I guess this is a
long way of me saying unnecessary orders
also this is just a bunch of clips and a
Maglite maybe and I think a meat
thermometer what is it between them neo
knows there's a deeper story here
because the script said exposition scene
at the top of the page what is it
between them also neo please the pronoun
game so the Trinity has to ask who the
hell he means by them say about the like
you say it's worth two in the bush you
either saw the Animatrix or you didn't
either way you're probably wondering why
they cram this stupid kid into this
movie I told you kid you found me neo
makes a casual reference to a far better
Matrix film steampunk offices steampunk
I don't care about Oracle's from
prophecies or messiahs
bad guy speaks for the audience knew not
everyone believes what you believe come
on you mean all the stuff neo did in the
first movie is simply a legend nobody
knows the story of how neo flew into an
agent and destroyed him everyone was
like that Morpheus he's always telling
tales
it's good to be home home is a piece of
this pan down shot is kind of cool but
it greatly exaggerated s-- the size of
Zions population and requisite housing
infrastructure requirements needy people
cock-block also the philosophy that neo
is some sort of Jesus becomes
mind-numbingly literal how many
girlfriends would let you refer to them
as your pee
my guess is none awesome badass chick
gina torres from aliens firefly and
angel gets about thirty seconds in this
movie taken dosha billion after all that
bullshit with tanks surviving in the
last movie this movie decides a tank
died somehow without explanation since
then basically you tank and seeing mia
do the things you can do like what
flying and calmly beating up agents we
saw all that in the first movie i give
you more polarizing figure Morpheus
somehow gets cheers from ninety-nine
percent of the crowd discount stomp and
who designed these fucking things dr.
Seuss it's obvious the Wachowskis
decided to put a weird rave scene in the
first act of both this and the first
Matrix movie what's not obvious is P why
we haven't had sex in ages we're dying
to fuck but hang on a few minutes while
I light all these candles so here we are
at the 30 minute mark
dancing pg-13 sex in an r-rated movie
hardly any ass kicked at this point and
we're at the exact same spot plot wise
as we were 20 minutes ago
this is sort of like neo thinking about
baseball's so he doesn't climax too soon
also did the orgasm make him think about
the nightmare or did the nightmare
assist in the orgasm hello - wait what
they obviously can't take physical items
with them through the phone line so is
this envelope symbolic I am so confused
right now does this mean that if neo
answered the call intended for Trinity
he could be inside Trinity that sounds
really dirty but seriously once agent
Smith takes this dude's body
why does a phone call transportation
systems still allow him to transport I
figure you have to contain the same DNA
of the guy you're transporting into or
else the matrix wouldn't allow it right
I just have anyone in mind we interrupt
this matrix equal to bring you boring
old men like me don't bother with making
points this movie is definitely gonna
make up for its violation of the
ass-kicking protocol later on but the
question is will I still be awake by the
time it gets there Neil wait that's not
that's not the important message from
the envelope that can't possibly have
come through the phone line from a
computer program into the physical world
is it no I don't believe in this stuff
but I do it's always brought me luck you
maintain a belief system that is based
on luck you know it took me a while to
figure out this was Agent Smith inside
this dude's body I mean we saw him twice
but both times he wore sunglasses or was
in shadows so at this point he just
seems like random dude who hates neo or
discount cypher from the first movie
stupid kid ex machina thing seriously
this dude's name is Bane did his parents
know that one day he would be possessed
by Agent Smith and become a bad guy
Batman much so he could easily stab neo
right now right neo isn't in the matrix
doesn't have access to his badass powers
and there are a million agent Smith's in
the matrix so even if he fails and dies
who cares you were gonna take a chance
and stab him in the back so why not now
also why a knife this dude has access to
guns right or am I still in charge of
art oh look we're talking about kung fu
as much as the next guy but is it only
supposed to be this boring I had to be
sure of what that you are the one that
dumbass fight we just saw proves new is
the one also Seraph plays the stop short
game so that neo has to ask him what the
hell he meant by I had to be sure you do
not really know someone I do you fight
them movie sets up a ridiculously
delicious premise but then never
delivers on it by having something
unexpectedly badass happen like neo
having to fight Morpheus or Trinity or
someone he thinks he knows in order to
find out they're actually traitors or
something instead no just a saying
do you angel dude you do
you know something I do you fight them
all so I keep telling my potential
girlfriends that but I always end up
bloodied at the antique shop ones doing
their job doing what they were meant to
do or invisible I think the movie could
basically have started here sentinels
are gonna attack Zion let's go to the
Oracle awesome ideas about the matrix
and rogue programs boom this is the
scene that finally sets the movie into
motion because you're the one that's not
what you said last time seems like every
time we meet I got nothing but bad news
no you got nothing but riddles and
instructions lady you have never had
anything resembling news hey can I go
back with you guys can you send me to a
place where I can get out of here no
okay
I'll fight a hundred Asian Smith's in oh
well so this fight goes on for six
minutes
agent Smith was a formidable adversary
in the first movie but hundreds of agent
Smith's are no match for neo in this one
feel free to use the restroom at this
point this fight is a lot of sound and
fury signifying nothing
wait this is a place where any asshole
can walk by and see this if so why is
this the first person stumbling on this
fight neo gets punched in the face a
zillion times but his glasses keep on
ticking this reminds me why doesn't he
just go ahead and fly the hell out of
here rubber neo number two also this is
a classic example of a scene that looked
fantastic on the big screen opening
weekend but then can never really be
viewed at home again without the
experience being soiled by how obvious
the CGI becomes finally in the hundred
Asian Smith's get smart and pile on neo
instead of doing the one by one
silliness that all bad guys do in fights
like this but even that Bruce totally
pointless neo could crush Superman with
his penis if he wanted to
haha they can't fly but why I mean he
can in the next movie he's not a human
being he's a computer program but he
still somehow has to earn or learn the
ability to fly now there's no worries
I'm sure they're just waiting to explain
that in the third movie right right
comprehension is not a requisite of
cooperation this motherfucker sounds
just like a machine let's get him also
harmonica nicolas because some things
never change Jason there's some things
do why don't any of these citizens turn
into an agent when they see neo and
Morpheus Morpheus is addicted people who
don't want to use the stairs why don't
any of the citizens eating at the
Merovingians restaurant turn into agents
when they see neo and Morpheus in their
action reaction cause since when do
programs get so damn wordy and preachy
every character near ones and two in
this movie has a master's degree in
philosophy
[Music]
orgasm man lots of people in this movie
keep saying what the audience is
thinking I'm gonna help you but only if
you kiss me cliche what that's not a
cliche that's just completely stupid
okay well no cliche but still plenty of
sin for this bullshit come on I mean
this is Monica Bellucci man make that
count kissing her like you do Trinity
would not be hard you know I'm serious
about this because I'm taking off my
sunglasses this kitchen doesn't have the
end fight scene from the raid to
happening in it right now why the long
introduction when you're just gonna kill
them how many people keep silver bullets
in their guns wait these guys are
werewolves the Oracle said stuff like
that was possible now the movies forcing
me to debate whether it's better that we
never see the werewolves or just be
happy that I got the reference I'm torn
you can either run to the restaurant to
tell my husband what I have done or you
can stay there and die Persephone lets
one henchman live to tell the husband
because promised to help implies
simultaneous promised to harm apparently
[Music]
that's racist nobody here has any powers
that can make this fight interesting
either we interrupt this matrix equal to
bring you the force also why doesn't he
do that kind of more often also why is
he being using weapons anymore after
realizing you can do like that so this
is still going you know fights aren't
good because they're longer they're only
good when you feel like the hero could
be in danger okay so I understand that
the keys change the rooms that you go
into but how do you change a room from
the outside and not be in that same room
yourself see here are guys who should be
fighting neo these dudes have amazing
powers and would present a challenge but
they're the only characters in this
whole movie who do anything cool hmm we
have the ability to become vapor how do
we ever get into this car is the knife
part of this twins program where it
turns to vapor when he turns to paper if
not why doesn't he just turn other
things into paper by touching them that
could come in handy you know what this
movie needs some good slow motion about
now for no reason Oh awesome
yeah yeah bullet holes appear and
disappear all over this scene but we
aren't really indignant picking little
details like that are these people
somehow oblivious to the war zone that
has been coming up on their ass for five
minutes
in Oakland man also empty highway behind
Chase is super empty
where the fuck is this radio guy in this
whole time he's just now calling in
shots fired dude
you are fired now that he's out of
bullets now's the time to vaporize over
to the other car where did all this
fucking traffic behind them come from
wait
so while the agent does this what is the
twin doing he has an absolutely huge
opening to kill Morpheus and Trinity and
make off with the key maker this van is
honking I guess for the incredible scene
of watching a guy turn into vapor and
land in the middle of the freeway
unharmed I mean are the people who live
inside the matrix muggles or something
they don't see magic right in front of
them this computer program cop has
terrible aim conveniently timed truck
with convenient motorcycles is
convenient these two make this jump but
only through the power of editing how
the hell aren't agents coming from all
over leaping into all these fucking
drivers and smashing the hell out of her
in the key-maker
I guess this is the only person on the
entire freeway who noticed the
motorcycle what how did these cops know
to drive down the exit ramp and how
could they be sure it was a completely
empty exit ramp that they could enter
the freeway with cool shot but as we've
seen people getting possessed by agents
go through all these convulsions before
changing the placement of the sword on
the side of the truck jumps several feet
between him stabbing it and him needing
to stand on it the next action I take
will require the removal of my
sunglasses oh look the sword jumped back
up to the top of the truck just in time
for him to grab it in his hour of need
moment then you're a man for one more
thing
delecia okay so do it already why has
the agent not already killed the
key-maker five times by now you know if
you're out there I could use some help
with Morpheus disappeared a neo in it's
answer of course neo saves the day no
one in this scene enters it at any time
other than the exact perfect second we
interrupt this matrix equal to bring you
a teaser trailer for the next one
there's a building inside this building
there is a level when no elevator can go
welcome to the most confusing scene in
movie history up is down left is right
and everything is happening all at once
and not at all while also being
discussed and explained in what appears
to be the same room where neo first met
Morpheus which would be a stupid place
for them to go but like I said there's
so much wrong and weird with this entire
scene I'm just gonna roll the dinger for
a couple seconds mom did he say bond you
know pound for pound Roy Jones is the
worst actor they could have gotten to
say this terrible line but like all
systems it has a weakness of course it
does sure as Morpheus said there are no
accidents just really convoluted ways to
get Trinity into the matrix when neo
doesn't wander in there
that whole goddamn building down yeah we
saw the dream at the beginning of the
movie - man there's no suspense now well
this timing is perfect actually do you
mind fighting with us for a little bit
just for a few moments while my friends
fix the power station crisis that we
don't even know about so that we don't
die when we open the door
awesome oh right that all a guard sees
badass chick in leather walk into a
restricted area and thinks of the words
little lady the mr. Smith's behind me
are just worthless they let neo do
whatever he needs to do before attacking
him again also some of these mr. Smith's
are obviously not Hugo Weaving
mr. Smith goes to bowling tonight oh man
this dude was riddled with bullets but
thankfully he had exactly enough breath
to get neo the instructions bitch dog
yep it's so obvious
I am the architect remember that earlier
scene that I said was the most confusing
one in movie history
yeah about that see I hadn't actually
watched any further than that point in
the movie when I said that there goes
some of my answers you will understand
and some of them you will not it's a
convenient thing to say when the
audience decides they have no clue what
the going on did he say you old white
prick
cuz that's racist so link told her the
bad guys were headed her way and to get
the hell out of there and she goes and
waits for the elevator the say we
designed it you can tell this is a movie
from 2003 when George W Bush gets
equated to Hitler there are two doors
the door do-right leads to the source
and the salvation of Zion the door to
your left leads back to the matrix to
her and to the end of your species so
basically no different from the choice
Batman has to make in Batman and Robin
previously on The Matrix Reloaded what
was that just moving faster than
anything I've ever seen first off you
know with your whole heart what that is
second off it can't be much faster than
when neo came out of the mountains to
save Morpheus in the key-maker from that
truck crash at the last minute this is
fucking awesome a dozen years before
mana steal this movie stole Superman's
thunder just a little bit and by the
same studio - atif I know
amazing you saw this before remember
also at the speed neo was flying
wouldn't this basically have been like a
747 crashing into Trinity will explain
his hand somehow reaching into her with
the use of green digital characters also
I don't know whether I'm supposed to
think this is amazing or be turned on
why didn't he just pull the bullet out
with the force neo has been powered up
from Superman Jesus to God Almighty
I can't I really relate to this guy this
guy is the audience only my amazement is
more anger based than his yeah you saved
me with a miracle kiss that shouldn't
work I reached inside your body and took
a bullet out and restarted your heart
but yeah we're even women
that's impossible someone in a sci-fi
movie declares something impossible
cliche
we enter up this second Matrix movie to
bring you lame is haram movie has the
balls to come up with a fantastic
cliffhanger ending after two hours of
relative boredom is to Hammond the
hammer is my penis also weren't there
way more than just three of those
sentinels back when they threw the bomb
alright the rest of them right behind
those first three and killing all these
fools right about now here's a
cliffhanger ending for your ass by the
way I had already sort of forgotten
about mr. Smith Bane and what he looked
like so seeing him upside down does me
no favors first time I saw this I was
like what was that evil neo come back in
six months we guarantee you'll be less
pissed off about this movie then
[Music]
it's a la ba did he say
everyone that's enough at the edge of
our hope at the end of our time we've
chosen not only to believe in ourselves
we will not go quietly into the night we
will not finish without a fight
we're going to live on we're going to
survive today we celebrate our
Independence Day
[Music]
yes Steve don't come here never like
you
alright guys now let's miss the blues
riff and be watch me for the changes and
try keep up okay
[Applause]
[Music]
he's after the Dragonball
is a safe it has begun